pour l'instant bien il ya eu lors qu ait
augmenté au niveau du couvre-feu
donc ça permet aussi compenser un petit
peu le fait qu on est maintenant confiné
niveau de la région d'île de france
ça va ça avait été annoncé
ça a été changé donc c'est 30 km
peut pas changer de région et les autres
personnes qui sont dans d'autres
départements ne peuvent pas venir dans
les régions qui sont confinés donc les
seuls départements et après au niveau de
la circulation via le couvre-feu sur à
19 heures et les 30 km eh ben on se
balade quand même parce qu'on peut
sortir la plupart à 10km max de chez
nous donc on profite pour prendre l'air
mais ça qu'on va faire attention et
rester au maximum chez nous n'ont pas
très claires comme tout le monde sait ce
qu'on entend pas mal des retours un peu
tout autour de nous pas très clair mais
quand même nécessaire parce qu'il va
falloir faire quelque chose pour qu'on
arrête ces virus au plus vite
comme les précédents en ce sens que je
sortais je continue à sortir et c'est
tout donc pour moi ça ne change
strictement rien à tel point que je me
demande finalement à quoi va servir ce
nouveau confinement très très confuse et
très très discutable discutable pour ce
faire sont exclus
comme pour ceux qui sont conservés par
incohérente et voilà on prend de l'air
c'est important mais pour l'instant ça
va très bien ben c'est un peu ce pas
très enfin j'ai pas vraiment pour ça
parce qu'on voit que ça n'y a pas
vraiment de changement au niveau des
routes qu'au niveau des cas ensuite
quand il veut où vient d'être des cas en
plus selon à la fin c'est logique
enfin qu'avec deux camps mais qui doit
être réduit et c'est au moins le
couvre-feu à plus tard c'est
complètement idiot parce que 10 km 30 km
on sait pas bien si pour les
attestations bon c
c'est pas clair c'est pas simple les
règles étaient vont être honnête pâte en
clair que ça étant donné que moi je ne
lis pas les infos et régulièrement et
j'ai pas de télé chez moi
donc j'étais un peu perdu au tout début
en tant qu'étudiant mais met ensuite en
parlant avec les gens aux alentours on
apprend assez rapidement les règles
alors je comprends que ce soit très
difficile à paris la situation sanitaire
mais c'est vrai que notre technique
étudiants on sature c'est vraiment un an
contre lens situation là et c'est
vraiment très dur à vivre sur notre vie
étudiante a juste été annulé avec
d'aider des étudiants qui ont fait 2 en
prépa qui font leur première école de
commerce et pour eux c'est très dur
parce qu'ils payent très cher pour
pourrait en fait surtout leur courant
dit essentielle donc voilà ça c'est un
peu dur là ça commence à faire beaucoup
voir
elles sont extrêmement confuse que
c'était 10 après 30 mois j'ai découvert
ça hier matin qu'on pouvait faire 30 km
enfin c'est n'importe quoi
la restriction exactement je n'ai pas
bien vu j'ai bien vu il y avait annoncé
depuis hier un pote à castres que
l'attestation de sortie au pas sorti une
nouvelle faction a paru ce matin sur le
ministère mais j'ai pas compris et il
n'y a pas compris j'ai rencontré au
marché de deux policiers
j'aurais dit messieurs poyer me donner
que quand il est question sur une
nouvelle formule de bain non parce qu'on
a rien compris non plus qu'on ne peut
pas se renier en plus donc pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de différence
pour moi je continue de l'or comme on
dit quoi